[Music]
i've always wanted to have kids
i can clearly picture myself throwing a
ball with them in the park
or sitting at the kitchen table helping
them with their homework
just like my dad used to with me
and i'm not just a future dad who really
wants to spend quality time with my
children
i'm also ambitious and dream of having a
high powered career
how about you how many of you are also
planning to have children
and would love to continue to pursue
your career
i see a lot of nodding heads and that
makes sense
more than three-quarters of us are
likely to become parents at some point
but despite so many of us wanting to be
the best parents that we can be
our current workplaces are not really
set up to allow us to be both great
parents
and pursue the careers that we want
even before covert most parents were
unhappy with their working situation
75 percent of working fathers
said that they would prefer to spend
more time at home with their children if
they had the chance
and 65 of stay at home mothers
actually said that they would like to
continue in paid work if they had the
opportunity
and even for those of you that aren't
planning to have kids these issues
should still matter to you
many of your friends family
and colleagues will parenting
is something that affects all of us
children are also negatively affected by
our current work
structures my work in early childhood
education
showed me first hand how important the
role of a parent is
in the first five years of a child's
development
research concludes that it's not whether
a parent works or not that matters most
to children
it's where the children have time at
home with their parents when they're
unencumbered by work stresses
children who had parents that were
overly invested in their career
tended to have more behavioral
difficulties than children whose parents
weren't
isn't this crazy so we know
that most of us are going to be parents
we know that we want to balance work and
family life
and we know that this affects the next
generation
and yet our inflexible work structures
are not set up to support us to pursue
both parenting and the careers we want
and for those of you who are thinking
well that's just the way it is we can't
change it
think back to a year ago i don't know
about you
but i had barely even heard of zoom
and now i spend more than half my life
on it
not only have we survived the world
going completely remote overnight
many organizations have actually thrived
something that we thought would have
been impossible a year ago
so let's leverage this moment let's
challenge
our mindsets and assumptions about how
we are meant to work
let's create a working society that
better supports parents
but what would a working society that
better supports parents actually look
like
well when i started my career in
consulting in australia
i was fortunate enough to experience
first hand
how a more flexible future could look
i worked on a project where i had two
direct managers
nicole and kirsten
they were doing what they described as a
job share
nicole worked monday to wednesday
kirsten
wednesday to friday with wednesday being
an overlap day
where they would both do handover to
each other
i must admit when i first started
working on this i was extremely
skeptical
i mean consulting is a pretty intense
job how was this going to work
but i couldn't have been more wrong the
next few months
were some of the highlights of my career
so far
both managers complimented each other
amazingly
one was a big picture thinker one
an analytical powerhouse basically
everyone was winning i
was getting two brains for the price of
one
the client was getting six days work for
the price of five
and nicole and kirsten were getting a
life that worked for them
they had found a way to continue working
in a
high-powered career that they loved
while also
being able to spend quality time at home
with their children
not only that but this work structure
meant that when they wanted to come back
to work full-time
the transition was so much easier
yet sadly experiences like this are rare
even when i tell people this story they
say things like wow
they're probably just good managers this
wouldn't work with everyone
this is exactly the mindset that i would
like to challenge
even if it's true that this isn't
possible right now
who's to say that it won't be possible
in the future
we are so innovative in so many areas of
our lives
and yet when it comes to the way that we
work
we seem to just blindly accept the
status quo
so what can we actually do to create a
working world that better supports
parents
today i'm going to talk about two
different strategies
first let's focus on the possibilities
rather than on the problems let's enable
more people
to do job shares like my managers did
let's allow more flexibility in the
times
and days that we work allowing people to
create schedules that work for them
and let's celebrate those who decide to
take a career break
or take parental leave to spend time
with their families
in effect let's iterate on our working
structures
in the same way that we iterate on new
product prototypes
let's leverage many of the modern tools
and technologies at our disposal
to overcome any problems that we come up
with
just as zoom and other tools have
enabled us to succeed over the past
year we're not going to get it right
first time
it might require us all to make some
changes
but in the end we will all be better off
for it
the second strategy let's change the way
that we show up to work
as leaders as managers and as
individuals
as leaders let's create policies that
better support parents
some examples
provide adequate parental leave
regardless of gender
and applaud those who decide to take you
up on it
we know how important the relationship
between parents and children is during
those first few years
so let's enable all parents to build
those relationships
consider providing subsidized child care
no one should ever have to choose to not
work because they're earning less than
the cost of their child care
your employees will be extremely
grateful but they will also be
much more productive and more likely to
stay with your company
as managers the next time you're
entrusted to manage someone
take the time to ask them about their
family situation
brainstorm ways that you could make the
workplace work for them
as well as for you and for the company
and finally as individuals push for this
yourself
as well just like my managers did
my fiance tess and i have had many
conversations about how we both want to
take time off work to spend with our
children when they're young
and how we both want to pursue
successful careers
we don't have all the answers yet but
these discussions
have helped us to define the type of
life that we want
and helped us to make decisions to help
us get there
with open dialogue drive and a dash of
ingenuity
let's fight the status quo be proactive
define what success looks like to you
talk candidly with those in your life
about it and encourage them to do the
same with you
as nicole and kirsten taught me all
those years ago
you never get what you don't ask for
so together let's build a better world
that where it is much easier to lead the
careers that we want to lead
as well as being the parents that we all
want to be thank you